Configuration is a kind of design
that assigns values to variables
to satisfy certain constraints.
Design in general can be very
complex and sometimes very creative.
Configuration is a kind
of very routine design.
The kind of everyday mundane design,
which is very very common.
While in design in the beginning,
you do not know the components or
the arrangement of
components looks like.
In configuration,
you already know all the components.
You simply have to figure out
an arrangement that will satisfy
constraints.
As an example,
consider the furniture in the room
in which you are sitting right now.
All the components, all the pieces
of furniture are already known.
The room is fixed.
You can't change the room either.
But you certainly can move
the furniture around.
There might be some constraints.
For example,
if the room has a couch and a TV,
then you might impose a constraint that
a couch has to be in front of the TV and
a certain number of feet away from it.
Given the constraint that all the
furniture must somehow fit into the room
as well as the constraint that the TV
must be in front of the couch,
you might first decide to place the TV
and the couch at specific locations.
And then having decided on
the location of the TV and
the couch, decide on the location
of the other pieces of furniture.
David, given the configuration is so
common, can you think of other examples?
>> So, it seems like we could talk a lot
about the physical arrangement of things
in different types of rooms.
For example, when an airline
configures a new airplane they
have to configure the arrangement of the
seats, the arrangement of the window,
the arrangement of the emergency
exits and various things like that.
But I think configuration really goes
beyond just configuring the physical
layout of items.
So, when I'm taking a picture with
my camera phone, for example,
I have to configure different
options like the focus, whether or
not the flash is on, my distance to
what I'm taking a picture of, and
a few other different things like that.
In doing so I'm still balancing
different restrictions.
So, for example, if I'm taking a picture
of a landmark I can only be so
close to it.
And therefore I might need to make
different decisions based on the focus
or the flash in order afford for
how far I can be from the landmark.
>> Design in general is a very common
information processing activity.
And configuration is the most
common type of design.
Now that we have looked at
the definition of a configuration task,
we're going to look at methods for
addressing that task.
Once again recall that the components in
case of configuration are already known.
We are deciding on the arrangement
of those components.
We are assigning values to specific
variables of those components, for
example, sizes.